did you know that Darth Vader and
several other Star Wars characters are
running for Parliament in Ukraine yeah
that's true I'm not making this up this
is happening not in a galaxy far far
away right here on October 26 they are
going to vote and well we've got some
video of some of the characters that are
actually running for Parliament in
Ukraine
Oh
nedda mozi spanish ozawa darth vader
candidate owner own in the patate elite
internet party Oh cry me alright I don't
speak Ukrainian but yes Internet party
so they're running on the internet party
they have all anyone that's running as a
Star Wars character so this includes
Darth Vader Chewbacca Padme Amidala
Master Yoda they had to legally change
their name to do this so these people
are now truly the Star Wars characters
that they proclaim to be and they are
actually running there are several other
videos you can find on youtube if you
want to see some more their Star Wars
commercials and well maybe we need some
of this in America I don't even know
where to start with this I didn't I
couldn't know Dick Cheney could run free
yeah you don't have to be born in
Ukraine to run in Ukraine that's maybe
that must be it for that guy yeah I
don't even know what the words were but
I would vote for him I like that to get
the lightsaber and there's always a harp
yeah he's saying something right there
some and he doesn't know how to play the
harp right can you see that you don't do
that you know you don't think [ __ ] he
was plucking with the wrong hand so you
say you're saying that their commercials
are as big [ __ ] as our commercials
look like it yeah I bet that's a costume
and he's not really darling do we first
off all right let's go with some silly
stuff first I mean maybe they need the
earth later because that's the only
person Putin listened to right I mean
yeah they need the dark side of the
force I are these people legitimately
insane or is this are they trying to
make a bigger political statement about
how stupid this um yeah I think it's the
latter but I think there is some element
like they're realizing how ridiculous
the political system is and our
political system is so self-important
and such [ __ ] I feel like we need
some of this like imagine if we had some
character that actually could get enough
popular votes to righties we've had
bigger clowns no really I mean if you
looked at all Louie Gohmert yeah well
this isn't the only country that does
this I was literally watching John
Oliver last night he was talking about
how Brazil since everyone's required to
vote now they just make a joke out of it
they have Jesus Satan and a guy who
shoots lasers out of his eyes all on the
ballot
yeah so you know maybe we need a little
more of this because maybe this is the
kind of lampooning that
we'll make people actually go okay you
know what this is what the people think
of us as a government we better you know
shape up because this is ridiculous
right so that is there is that less is
that more ridiculous than our system
here really I mean with all the clowns
and the fakery and we all know it's
[ __ ] I mean when they do the debates
and if you're winning at the time they
put you in the center right and the
further you're losing but then as you
start gaining more popularity they put
you more I mean it's all the fixes in
matters exactly and the fix is in and we
all know it so I really think we do need
something like this to shake the system
well obviously the system is corrupt
right so that's why we get suits cloned
but you need to talk about the debates
used to be the debates were real debates
and they were run by a third party
called the League of Women Voters well
the course the corrupt corporate and
owned
Democrats and Republicans decided to rig
the system even more they got rid of the
democracy that was involved in that and
that got rid of the citizens so now they
corporately pick their corporate
hand-picked journalists to ask them non
questions questions which they get
before the debate beforehand and also
it's not even there by the definition of
what a debate is what we're seeing when
they do these debates it's not even a
debate anymore what was the old debate
the link in Douglas the lincoln-douglas
those were debates we're going to
challenge someone's ideas and go back
and forth and question them directly now
they have rules where sometimes you're
not even allowed to look at the person
you're not allowed to address them
directly that's exactly what I was
thinking I mean what a bunch of babies
like hold on that's not fair
hey I didn't know that in advance B he
said it's super me so let's go to
commercial so I can reap powder and and
and kick that guy's uh you know helpers
ass that's actually a funny point also
that I think that because of HDTV it's
also changed it that when I watch the
debates now like when I was watching the
the Biden Palin one from six years ago I
remember thinking Biden had so much work
done in the hair plugs and that that's
what I kept focusing on instead of
anything he was saying looking in the
televised president yeah alright so Star
Wars in the Ukraine last thought on this
did did we give up on the Ukraine what
happened they had that whole thing work
out I thought it all worked out it's
good it's all fixed right do that do you
have any idea have that thing
because we stopped talking about that
because you know the ISIS thing and then
Ebola coming to get us through Mexico
according to yes Ukraine super important
though it's so important that we don't
talk about it anymore
or you know the plane that went down
with all the crime scene of all the
bodies that removed and whatever we're
done with that right yeah joking aside
last I heard Russia now pretty much owns
Crimea and they were moving nuclear
warheads there so you know hopefully
Darth Vader can fix that